the principle of least privilege is
fairly straightforward
every user should only be granted the
permission they need only when they need
them
implementing this principle however can
be complex
and then add in the need to scale at a
pace of a growing cloud
in today's video we're diving into iam
recommender a google cloud tool that
makes implementing least privilege and
securing your cloud easier
following the principle of least
privilege is one of the core tenets of
maintaining a strong security posture
unfortunately as cloud practitioners we
don't implement this practice enough
according to gartner research by 2023 99
of security failures will be the cloud
customers fault
why is that
well enforcing this privilege can be
complex and labor-intensive
first you need to understand each user
permissions they have and which ones
they need for their day-to-day work
next you need to identify which
permissions each user is likely to need
in the future so that you minimize the
toil of incremental updates
then you need to translate these
requirements into iim policies and roles
finally you need to establish processes
to regularly re-evaluate these policies
remove excess permissions and monitor
their use closely
oh and since the cloud is built to scale
this overall process needs to scale as
well iam recommender is a tool that
eases enforcing leads privilege by
helping automate steps and making it
possible to manage them efficiently at
scale
how does it work
iam recommender creates daily policy
recommendations and serves them to you
automatically
it does this by looking back at the
permission usage over the last 90 days
and finding used and unused permissions
next a machine learning model looks at
the use permissions and determines
inferred permissions
these are permissions that have been
granted but not yet used however we can
predict that they will likely be needed
in the future based on similar usage
patterns observed elsewhere
iam recommender then uses this
information to recommend a new role that
removes unused permissions and keeps
inferred permissions
the best part
no configuration or setup is required
google cloud stores a log data that
supports its functionality and there is
no charge to you
let's head into the cloud console and
see recommender in action
recommender is built directly into the
im page
where it shows you the permissions you
have given and how many are actually
being used
again there is no need to collect and
parse through activity logs we've done
all that hard work for you
in our example project you can see that
there are some users using very few
permissions that they've been granted
a light bulb icon indicates where
recommenders ml models have determined a
better fitting role
click in to get more details about the
recommended role and which permissions
will be removed or added
you can take action and apply the change
by clicking the apply button if
recommender identifies a common
permission usage pattern that does not
map to an existing role it may suggest
creating a new project level custom role
in this case you can customize the
recommendation adding or removing a
specific permission before you apply the
changes this customization action also
helps continually train the ml model for
future recommendations
over on the recommendations history tab
you can see all the recommendations you
have applied and revert them if needed
it also tracks your progress towards
least privilege
another area of the console is the
recommender hub this gives another view
of your iam recommendations as well as
the option to export them to bigquery so
that you can perform custom analysis
across your organization
in addition to retrieving
recommendations in the console you can
also use the recommender api or the
google cloud cli gcloud command now
you're ready to use iam recommender to
help strengthen security of your
deployment
it gives you back time by helping
automate and bringing ml powered
intelligence to the process of enforcing
least privilege to learn more about im
recommender and the other tools that are
part of the policy intelligence toolbox
check out cloud.google.com slash policy
intelligence